foreign
[Music]
was sent to a hospital with an unusual
problem
there was a USB cable stuck inside of
his
penises trying to charge his iPhone this
happens a lot yeah this is like a thing
is it this is a thing was it a link I
think we did do this no this is a
there's another one did we do this a
long time ago yeah this happened before
I think this happens a lot more than we
think I think it happens every week but
was it a lightning cable or like a USB
that's how you know if we did it before
yeah if it's the new USBC it's USBC yeah
it's probably new wow it's a new one
yeah because back in the day it used to
be like a like a like a like a blow
dryer in the socket but even as a 13
year old I never want to put anything in
my pizza I always wanted my I always
wanted to put my penis into things yeah
like even if I was laying on the beach I
want to go oh does it feel good to put
into sand I never wanted to put anything
in my hole in between couch pillows see
that
just wanted something to be inside me
um
like something snug to fill you up okay
so if you guys ever had any kidney
stones yes when you pass a kidney stone
through pee how much does it hurt how
much do you calm like
how many ounces do you come it hurts
well the whole experience is so bad
right by the time you actually pass it
you're kind of just like like broken
mentally anyway yeah but yeah it hurts
like it hurts right so what I don't
understand is the people that want to
put something inside
as if it's going to be pleasurable I
don't know because it's the other
direction yeah like that you ever have
kitty Stones no but I've heard it's a
friend of mine described it it's like as
if someone flicked the tip of your penis
that's how much it hurts worse than that
I think I can handle it it looks worse
it looks my penis it's I had a well I I
had many doctors that I talked to about
this [ __ ] but like a nurse told me she
said that she's given birth without pain
meds and it's the worst pain she's ever
felt in her life Jesus having kidney
stones it's like wow wow well she's had
kidney stones too yeah the nurse did she
was like relating to me because I was
still going through it because I hadn't
had I hadn't passed my name it was too
big it was like a centimeter
it's [ __ ] crazy with a laser laser a
big laser though goddamn right big laser
fatty laser yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah a
real girthy laser yeah you know what I
mean um so like so that kind of pain
imagine now someone's sticking a USBC
cable
no so guess what he was trying to do
though charge his iPhone no charges
peanut why would he charge well because
people know that if you had salt and
water it conducts electricity so PP has
salt and water so it's like they can
like charge his iPhone and the body's
got a lot of electricity that's right in
the Matrix do you use us as a battery
he's trying to become one of those
Egyptian batteries from like that is
exactly what he's trying to do really I
become an Egyptian battery
I'm [ __ ] kidding guys no the answer
is that's stupid dude he's trying to
transfer the table up he's trying to
transfer all his uh pornos to his ball
sack hard drive oh it's a USB heart it's
a it's a USB hard drive that's okay
that's actually what he was trying to do
really no well he was using VR and he
was trying to get he was trying to get
the point closer to his body no you
[ __ ] idiot I didn't vote for that one
that was his part
put a flash drive in his ass and was
trying to connect him this room is just
too creative okay is it because okay you
know like the sensation of ejaculating
comes from Once you ejaculate that's
where the sensation it shoots out yeah
was he trying to like stick that cable
in so that he could like make a longer
ejaculation oh he's trying to ejacul
hack oh yeah yeah okay I don't think we
were it's been a while since we were 13.
but it's a very Primal reason he was
trying to measure his dick with a USB
cable oh oh but inside so you wanted to
see it from the inside well I guess so
this kid's not very smart I thought I
guess he thought it would be really
accurate I don't know I guess he doesn't
have any rulers around his house anyway
so that means that when they were taking
like height measurements at his school
did they
[Laughter]
make sure the measuring tape is hitting
your big toe let us know when it hit he
probably went to a [ __ ] circus school
that's why they tie a weight to it it
just goes through his foot yo that
[ __ ] hurts why did he do that like
like you most are 50 15 year old boys or
whatever 13 year old boys I think he's
lying you think he was curious and he
was jacking off with it some weird [ __ ]
yeah yeah he shouldn't have [ __ ] up
porno and I think he was he's making it
up later I was trying to measure myself
he just wired all [ __ ] he's all [ __ ]
up in his head what uh is this kid from
the UK or something sounds like some UK
[ __ ] I can attest to this yeah is he one
of your people or one of our people uh
he's one of your people he's a Japanese
kid so [ __ ] you dude
as a Japanese I would have to say we are
like the offshoot Asians that are the
horniest and do weird [ __ ] and more like
likely to be a little bit on the school
shooter side so then the rest of the
other Asians probably don't have a
libido if you look at Japanese people
um so so yeah why do you think Japanese
people are the most horniest because
they like to have vending machines of
underwear that they can buy and sniff it
like yeah so that they're
ink is a little bit
dominate they dominate the Asian porn
scene I think baseball Japanese out of
everybody unfortunately this article
doesn't say his race so we can't use it
to divide and conquer each other
what a [ __ ] article how are we
supposed to make any progress do you
want a serious answer yeah it's because
there's no sexual shame like it's just
natural there's no there's no dick
Festival yeah there's not there's it's
just a it's like breathing like you
gotta [ __ ] come well then why why do
they blur the hoo-ha yeah yeah why do
they blow their that's illegal showing
it's an old law but showing penetration
is illegal you don't think they're ever
gonna change that in the in the near
future but also so if you're born in
Japan you have an 8-bit private part
like it's just yeah bad Graphics I was
born in the states so I'm lucky it's not
like do you think blurred we should form
a military base what's the government
what's the government name for uh in
Japan like do they have a
what do you mean what's a government
body what do they call it over there I
don't know
the Japanese Parliament they have a
congress yeah when they overrule that
dumb ass [ __ ] law about pixelating
the dick and balls I wish they will do
you think do you think Japan is just
going to be [ __ ] hyped and just it's
all going to be good finally yeah do you
think they're gonna be celebrating the
streets I think that the the repression
just makes people hornier I actually do
oh yeah probably but they they have them
unpixelated yeah but I I think it's for
like smut bro my guess is that's what
they pay for the uncensored oh that's
like the only fans
it's a paywall yeah it's a paywall okay
it's not like accept it it's still like
perverted and [ __ ] weird it's just
not like the same do you guys like
looking at puss like where like do you
like looking at [ __ ] puss and like like
you wanted to bat wings that [ __ ] apart
and like you wanna
put on your face look up in there
you wear like a scarf Joe I think it
depends it doesn't work wait was the
next thing was the next question you
just want to look in there and like
stick a USB cable no not with the USB
camera yeah USBC though yeah I'm all in
yeah small
um yeah am I a connoisseur I like I like
the look of one yeah you like staring at
it I'm like yeah look in the eye it
depends though like if it's like
doctor's office kind not really nah oh
yeah yeah but don't try it well
I didn't know we're talking about
doctors off I thought we were talking
purely it's up to you it's like art what
do you mean dog what do you mean dog
stuff is kind of like as in you're the
doctor and you're looking at it or
you're like it's on legs are on stirrups
well it's all uncomfortable or you're
about to put an IUD in and that's kind
of cool too it's kind of like a fantasy
I just like to stare like yeah edge of
the bed like this with your feet
dangling in there just pick it up that's
nice hi yeah hi I'm like I'm I'm always
looking at one like this do you see it
saying hi back to you like hey
and I'm like oh hello
and then some of them are like hello Joe
what do you think a vagina really sounds
like vocally yeah yeah I don't know why
we're getting masculine voices to the
vagina I think it's a masculine British
man yeah hello Joe how's your day today
will you be entering me
open the gates you look like a little
child with your feet up
that makes me want to punch it no no you
want to punch it I don't want it I don't
want that Daniel Craig [ __ ] talk that
was Daniel Craig to you
I don't know
I don't know that's that's a good
question what would it sound like I
would I would think it's like kind of
nice hi
like do you think it's like a a younger
girlier version voice of your of your
girl
when I say younger I mean like two years
younger
it's not the same voice there's a big
difference
nice try Waltz you're not beating me man
that's not it that's not it what if
[ __ ] only talks like uh Pitch Perfect
style it's only in acapella songs I'm
out
as long as they're not matchups yeah
wait wait what if it's rapping to you
but not like cool rap but you know like
those rap those girl singers do like
because rap became real rap was like
really big and you mean where it's all
BH Beach let's go to the beach it's just
like some simple rep yeah like pop rap
like what if it was like like the [ __ ]
wrapped to you in like that pop rap no I
don't like that b to the a to the r to
the T like Kesha rapping oh no no no no
I'd rather have a British man's voice
yeah legit yeah yeah I'd have that way
more than a distinguished gentleman Yeah
Siri change your voice
you look mighty chipper today it's more
comforting to me that's a good Daniel
Craig you like that
Bond James Bond the boys coming out of a
dude's ass must be the most awesome rap
you've ever heard
sounds like a Rick Ross Maybe
I'm in
I'm in or dare I say Nick Cannon
[Music]
oh